[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits I'm Rhett and
I'm link joining us today at the round
table of dimmed lighting is entrepreneur
investor author and co-founder of Reddit
one of the most popular websites on the
Internet Alexis Ohanian
I got to take issue with you there link
you said dimmed lighting again I'm just
you know you can say it how you want to
but it's dim lighting the lighting is
dimmed but dim lighting is I mean I'm
just I'm gonna take a stand here I
really think you should take the deal I
- I'm gonna take a stand and it's dimmed
so you say - alexis sold reddit just
over a year after starting it but now
he's back as a reddit board member but
when he's not reading he's focusing his
time and energy on founding and
investing in companies that fit his
model of creating something people love
and making the world suck less alexis is
an inspiration to a generation of people
born on the internet and he demystifies
entrepreneurship by encouraging people
to use the tools around and to be
self-starters and to do the things they
really want to do
he's also recognized as one of the most
influential activists of net neutrality
and a champion of Internet freedom
Forbes actually called him the mayor of
the internet well a Forbes says it well
they didn't they say must be true in
this biscuit we talked with Lexus about
the role of Waffle House in the
formation of Reddit the origin of a Mas
ask me anything in case you didn't know
what that was the latest on net
neutrality and protecting the internet
as a level playing field and what reddit
reveals about humanity in general we had
a great time talking to Alexis and I
hope you'll have a great time listening
to it but first maybe you've got an idea
for the next reddit well don't let
somebody else take that domain name
register a domain name now and put your
idea online how does $1.99 sound 199
dollars one dollar and 1900 that sounds
really good link com domain go to
godaddy.com and use our code GMM you
want I have to pee right now but I'm
gonna hold it calm yes I do cuz only
were just I was thinking that how'd you
know I also was thinking could you see
us s no I had I had to pee right now but
I'm going to hold it calm calm were you
thinking - dot-com part because
for a dollar ninety-nine he can be yours
only with our coupon code well I did not
anymore I just took that one no you did
while you were talking I just registered
it visit godaddy.com and enter code GMM
at checkout for a new comm for only
$1.99 I know it's a little interesting
we're using GMM code on ear biscuits but
guys it's always a good mythical morning
and we do both shows so you know don't
get too confused about this some
limitations apply see website for
details now on with the biscuit be read
that you you were planning on becoming
an immigration lawyer yes but had an
epiphany in a Waffle House tell us about
that Waffle House you all will
appreciate this I you know what so I
went to school in Virginia
Charlottesville UVA and there's a waffle
house in route 29
where none of them out here man we
really missed it this is why I know
y'all appreciate it this is I did a
college tour for my book and I visited
81 or 82 universities talking about my
story and entrepreneurship we're trying
to get people to do amazing technology
and part of it is like go to Waffle
House and have an epiphany there and
unfortunately that's like a point in
your like PowerPoint presentation no
literally I'll say I will send you the
deck and I I do that in Atlanta and it's
like a standing ovation right everyone's
there 7 within a mile radius yes it
meets intently that's why I know way too
much waffles that's why it's yellow and
black is cuz the guy who founded it was
a Georgia Tech alum I don't know if this
is really his people's opinion so there
might be some Bulldogs out there who are
like never going to Waffle House
you know there are parts of the country
where no one has ever been to or even
heard of Waffle House and at that point
slightly flat and I have just dislike
delete yeah
what is the furthest west what is the
furthest west that they go I mean it
Romo probably yeah that's right yeah I
mean they're mmm yeah it can't be
further than yesterday yeah that's fact
not much passes yeah we can change that
though that's where a lot of good things
stop you know West Texas you like your
hash browns
oh man
scattered and smothered so cheese and
not in not in America dope I like the
crack the crunch man I'm a simple man
I like I'm scattered smothered and
what's onions covered capped not capped
you totally made that up how do you eat
a cheese mushrooms oh I don't like it at
I do capped smothered covered what do
you put when you when you put jalapenos
in there spiced I don't know everything
that they offer oh we got it we got a
brunch oh yeah whatever I'm a simple man
I don't I try not to I I just don't
wanna ruin it but you had an epiphany
there oh yeah
right cuz I was gonna be a lawyer and
and I walked out of an LSAT prep class
on a Saturday morning with my buddy Jack
and we just went to waffles cuz we were
hungry we decided 3:00 a.m. we were
totally drunk no we were that's the
probably recovering okay but it was it
was very early on a Saturday and it was
in one of these SAT things like Kaplan
does where they put you in a room it's
like a mock oh sorry LSAT it's like a
mock LSAT where you're in there for like
however many hours and and I just I
don't know an hour in we looked at each
other we're just like do we really want
to be here and and we were both hungry
and so we just got waffles instead and
soused we left and it was it was a weird
thing because you have to imagine like
for all of I guess for the first two or
so years of college I was really I was
obsessing over things like my GPA I was
taking I was so just neurotic about I
was a history major too and I loved
history but it was eating away at me
because I was thinking like I gotta
study for the LSAT like if I don't do
this I don't do this and I was trying to
check all these boxes and for me to just
walk out of that and then sit there
eating waffles I realized you know maybe
I don't really want to do this and if
it's gonna cost as much as it's gonna
cost and it's three years and a piece of
paper that says I can basically only be
a lawyer
I should really want to do it and it was
then that I just decided oh the law I'm
gonna have to figure out something else
to do with my life unfortunately that
was you know start a company with my
buddy Steve and so the complete epiphany
like the complete plan didn't scatter
out of Waffle House it did not have it
covered right from the start it was a
general feeling at that point that I I
got to do something that I want
yes but it wasn't like oh and hey and
here's the I here's the plan and it's on
the napkin I did not I did not draw this
on a waffle Hopkin but your your first
idea was food-related right was yes
sheets sheets gas station other
institution that a lot of folks
depending on where you grow up have no
idea it is a big luxurious gas station
like a Wawa it's like when you drive in
the sheets it's like you're in Vegas
yeah like I'm not afraid I'm afraid of
sheets really you can't press the
freaking screen while the gas is pumping
and get a cheeseburger by the time it's
done yeah yeah but when I'm pumping gas
in that those fumes they're like going
up my nose
I immediately crave a hotdog mm-hmm and
I want to touch a screen and order it
yeah because you're normal right yeah
that's you invented sheets is that what
Steve Hoffman and I invented cheese we
we were that was the that was the place
like you'd look forward to stopping when
you were driving and he needed to get
gas because you knew that you'd have
this amazing touchscreen inside so you
wouldn't it's not that I don't like
talking to people it's just that like it
was cool cool experience in 2004 like to
know that you could just like walk in
touch the screen place your order and
then go like mess with Lanham buy some
peanut M&Ms or something it's one of
those moments where you you're like I am
in the future yeah I love those moments
when you're at Sheetz and you're
touching the screen you realize you're
in the future and and my buddy Steve
ever the efficient technologist was like
why do I have to go inside to touch the
screen I have a phone why can't I just
place the order out here and then it'll
be ready and and he's telling you this
and we were having I would probably we
were probably drinking eating some pizza
whatever sitting around the living room
and I'm like but dude you could use this
anywhere like anywhere you want to skip
the line you could just use your phone
now remember this is before smart like
the smartest phone at this point was
like a blackberry or a trio this has
gotta happen on a flip phone yeah and so
this is like how do we so basically
using SMS like is there way to allow
people to place orders and and the more
we thought about it the more we thought
this could this could change the world
right classic startup stuff okay and and
I talked him out of his he had a job
lined up pretty much from freshman year
he had a job at a software company in
that was like soon as you graduate like
we don't care what your GPA is like you
got a job you're great and I talked him
out of it to work on this company with
no certainty whatsoever no funding
probably no hope of being profitable
anytime soon I think just based on the
premise that we could keep working in
our underwear yeah and like hopefully
work on stuff that we loved and play
video games the rest of the time and
it's a good thing he said yes cuz I did
you lay the groundwork for this or what
was the what exactly happened with the
idea so we did all the things and it's
funny now if someone just were to hit
Google I mean YouTube didn't even exist
but like you could just you could find a
wealth of resources for like how to
start a company maybe you guys just
trust me like there weren't there just
weren't nearly as many back then and so
we went that like I remember asking my
commercial law professor like how do we
start a company and he was like well we
go down and talk to this lawyer I'm a
professor I don't know but I mean in
theory he just go talk to this lawyer so
we found a lawyer in town who
incorporated us as a LLC and Virginia's
lawyers are really good at introducing
you to other lawyers I wonder if he got
a kickback profess you know but you know
so we got the little certificate of
incorporation I went and you know opened
a bank account of Bank of America
all this stuff that like at the end of
the day excuse me at the end of the day
wasn't that important like it was just
the sort of window dressing stuff you
have to do and then just started talking
to restaurants in Charlottesville did
you have a name yeah it was very proud
of this let me know what you guys think
it's called my mobile menu or or mmm oh
not bad yes good very 2004 no I like it
I'm happy I'm happy it eventually got
shut down so you we'd worked on this for
a year and I talked to everybody there
not a lot of restaurants and trial tool
but I talked to all of them and I was
like how do we get you signed up like
let's the way we were gonna hack it was
gonna involve fax machines because at
this point faxes we're the way people
were doing online um but read quotes
ordering it's like you'd see your
computer and like it was delivery comm
campus food you'd go online place the
order and then it would spit out of
inside of the restaurant right so not
the most high-tech solution but we
thought all right we can hacky we can
make this work and we spent about a year
doing research sort of signing up not
quite yeah basically signing up clients
and then we went and had this chance
encounter with this guy Paul Graham who
Steve it idolized who was really making
a name for himself as this sort of
Internet pundit and we heard him go talk
on our senior year spring break we went
up to Boston we were the only kids in
Charlottesville who were going north for
spring break their senior year and there
was a lot of snow we heard this dude
give a talk and I approached him
afterwards and said I probably said dr.
Graham it would totally be worth the
cost of buying you a drink to get your
opinion on our startup like we came all
the way up from Virginia and I think
that's what clinched him because he was
shocked that we I don't know had trains
or I like that we came all the way up
from Virginia and I was like yeah we
came Virginia and he met with us for
coffee that night we pitched him on mmm
and he loved it and we were like yes we
did it like this is amazing like this is
the guy he had started a startup in the
last bubble sold it to Yahoo done very
well like this was a guy who Steve
really respected we're like this is
amazing like we have an advisor now we
have a mentor we might even have an
investor if we play our cards right
mm-hm and about a month later he
announced Y Combinator which was this
pretty radical idea where they would
give a little bit of funding was about
$6,000 per founder to like basically
just work for a summer three months just
do nothing but write code and get users
for your company in exchange for a
little bit equity and then the end of
those three months they'd set you up
with a bunch of investors for like a
demo day and you'd pitch what you're
talking about or to a roomful of rich
people and hopefully they raise some
checks and you know this announcement
comes up and Steve and I look at each
other we're now probably two months away
from graduating at UVA and and to be
clear we're not like the cool drop out
story like we we did get our degrees but
we saw this we thought this is amazing
like we met this dude he liked our idea
he started this program to invest in
companies just like us we have to apply
so we did we think we got a good shot of
course he already liked this so we get
back on the train we go up for
interviews because we had to meet the
rest of his partners and we pitched and
it was the pitch of our lifetime dude we
it was amazing everyone's ass
and questions and I've just got answers
and Steve's just killing it we're like
flipping open your phone and like type
in text and then food without hearing it
was everybody's going mmm yes they loved
it loved it and that night we got the
guy was like Campbell Soup already has
the corner on them mmm that's Rover we
could rebrand it we could have mmm
that's different this is just one oh
right right Oh soup I've only watched
Shark Tank I've not been on it but you
can imagine this room was electric and
everyone was so excited and so that
night Steve and I go out we were
celebrating and we get the call and they
let us know that they had rejected us it
was all it was awkward yeah so so the
good news was we were already drinking
so then it went from celebratory drinks
to like misery drinks and and it sucked
it really sucked indeed he did he give
you a reason yeah yeah and it was it was
it was the right reason yeah he said
it's just it's so early right now too
soon um you know you're both the setups
are gonna be really hard because getting
so consumers are only going to use it if
the restaurants are on it getting the
restaurants on board it's kind of a
chicken-egg figure but the restaurants
back then especially we're like not at
all interested in any kind of technology
in their back rooms like they're still
using fax machine right and the
technology we would offer was kind of an
ugly hack like it would have been some
kind of SMS there was no App Store so it
would have been these ugly text messages
like he just it was just too early but
it led to the net did it lead to reddit
was that well step well that night oh
yes we were drinking and and it sucked
it really did and then the next morning
we're hungover on the train back to
Virginia and we got a call from Waffle
House get in here you we got we got fax
machines at every location you know it's
it may not be too late for this yes but
I I pick up and it's Paul and he says
listen we
still don't like your idea yeah but we
like to deal you got we were you on that
call yes that's exactly what he said
and it was specifically it wasn't even
Paul I have to give credit where it's
due one of his other then one of the
other founders of Y Combinator Jessica
Livingston she was the one she was the
only advocate of the four who bangs on
table and was like their ideas terrible
but I really like them we should give
him a shot and she was the one who got
us in and and so you were in so we were
there was a twist and they said listen
as long as you change your idea work on
something different worked on everything
else start on something in a browser I'm
working working on for over he cannot
back shoot it in the head Yeah right I
get about it yeah that's what happened
and we went we got off the next stop
took the first train back up to Boston
we were somewhere like I don't
Connecticut at the time and they gave
parameters they said something browser
related yeah they said don't build it in
a phone build it for something in a
browser and we sat down for about an
hour and add like a brainstorming
session and and PG or Paul basically
said well what do you all do every
morning like solve a problem you have
every morning like sit me down let's
talk this is it he's he's very good
great advisors I think are really good
at sort of drawing up this stuff with
questions and Steve is like I read slash
that every morning and and I'm really
interested in the commenting section
there's a lot of interesting content
there and I would their tabs were new
thing back then and so I'd open up like
20 tabs every morning and look at 20
different news websites just to get a
broad range and he was like do you think
either one of you have a good solution
for that like do you think either one of
you are getting all the sort of news you
think is interesting and we're like well
no these don't seem optimal and he was
like alright build a solution for that
build your front page for the Internet
and I was like okay this guy wants to
give us 12 grand to build a front page
for the Internet sucker all right we'll
do it and and so that's that's what we
set out to build and that was the that
was that one phrase we tried to fulfill
and are still trying to fulfill to this
day now what was the process like so
when you do when you you're given this
money you go to San Francisco right or
no this is all in boss back then it was
in Boston Boston and they put you up
someplace and what kind of space do they
give you to work like what
day to day so what was so and this was
one of the things that set it apart that
set Y Combinator apart was they didn't
give you space and they didn't give you
a place to live like they basically said
here is a check you're grown you'll
figure it out and and if you're gonna
start a company like you should be able
to figure out I don't know how to rent
an apartment right right you're in bunk
beds next to other guys like that is how
like incubators that is how that would
that's how they were always done like
that would be the true way of doing
things was well it was exactly that like
let's just we'll take care of you we'll
give you a space we can come in and you
know they're thinking really was like
just just go figure it out you can come
once a week for these dinners we'll
bring in an expert who will talk off the
record about what it was like starting a
company you're doing them various things
and there you'll meet your sort of
compatriots the other dozen or so
companies that are in this batch but
that's it and and and you'll meet once a
week and it creates this weird like
social this this weird social dynamic
where you're all friends none of you are
actually competitive with each other but
you're competitive because you're all
working on companies and you feel so
like guilty if a week goes by and you
haven't shipped anything interesting or
meaningful because like if you saw each
other every day it'd be like what you do
yesterday
oh I you know I changed the color of a
button to blue and and that that doesn't
feel very meaningful but in a week
you've got enough time to actually ship
like real features and see real growth
and so it just created this amazing
dynamic and we were in the first batch
that is reddit but in the years since I
mean some of the most I mean Airbnb
Dropbox twitch formerly known as
justin.tv stripe like these are amazing
billion-dollar companies they're all
part of the same program they're all
sort of all came out a lot happening
through Y Combinator exact same way and
dude it's just it's been amazing to
watch and be a part of because I get to
see I mean front row like I remember
when Airbnb was just three dudes who
were just barely scraping by trying to
fund their business with I mean they
were they were selling cereal boxes and
then when they couldn't sell a bunch of
them they just ate them and lived off
them but like that was a struggling
startup for year-and-a-half oh yeah fan
of air beam look at it now I know that
San Francisco is - with all those taxes
they just base
what how quickly did it take off I mean
what was the the launch of reddit was it
at the beginning of this process was it
live and how different is it now than
when it first launched
all right so aesthetically not terribly
different I need to work on that not
drastically but when we we were the
actually were the first Y Combinator
company to launch we basically showed up
in June and about three weeks later four
three four weeks later Steve and I
launched the first version of Reddit so
it's like every weeks worth of
development and it was that moment yeah
of launch because it I would imagine
it's gotta be pretty anticlimax
extremely anti-climactic because you put
this thing online and and also cuz it so
v you don't there's no social media so
you have no way to really tell people
about it other than like I had run a
message board in college and so I had
maybe like 500 emails and so I emailed
all those people we emailed our
collective a bunch of people are
probably listening being like email but
like dude that's when we made videos
back in the early days we had a an email
list that we it still converts a giver
it's super well but when you when ours
didn't we had like two people actually
use the site and tell em I need it go to
my website where what the the pitch was
and back then there was only one from
page you know now there's like there's
over 8,000 active communities on the
network but there was just one back then
because it was just me and Steve and we
were just submitting the links and we
would say like here's a place where you
will find what's new interesting online
and anyone can contribute you just
submit a link choose a headline and then
people will vote it up if they like it
and vote it down if they don't and it'll
leave this like rising and falling list
of just interesting stuff from all over
the internet and the premise hasn't
changed much it's just we're now at a
scale we like the ambitions of the site
back then were let's build this place
we're like we have this vast network of
thousands and thousands of communities
so if you're into if you're into the Tar
Heel
there's a community for you now we are
not oh geez oh wait NC State yes okay no
there was one other option and I didn't
want to even say it you didn't put a
third at least we're really into the
Wolfpack because somebody's got to be
right yeah yeah alright somebody if
you're really in the Wolfpack really an
NC State there will be a community for
you there if you're really into there's
one called reddit Lac aristos which are
people just showing off photos of their
fingernail polish or red found grilled
cheese so yeah yeah that's a great
there was actually a schism there
because people were posting images of
what I guess are consumed considered
melts yeah and they were like this
doesn't belong on our grilled cheese
this is a community for grilled cheese
not for melts if you add anything they
the purest just want cheese yeah right
yeah I I don't want to get in the middle
of this i I want to believe that these
two communities can coexist
like the melts and the grilled cheese
right like if but that's the but they
can't they can each have their own
subreddit exactly and and that was the
that was the hope it's just when we got
started we had two users
me and Steve but the vision was what it
is now yes rub basically the essence of
it that was that was the one thing we
got right we screwed up a lot of other
things but then yeah how do you get
there you got okay you posted a link and
then he don't know he did Steve actually
the first ever submission or edit by me
was it it was it was a link to the
Downing Street memo and and I I
submitted it and again there's only two
people on the website and I see it gets
down voted I'm looking I'm looking
across the table I'm like really really
there's no one else and and and there's
got to be a thought that's like this
website may always just be me and Steve
let's change it to me and Steve dot-com
well we we wanted so desperately we knew
because we were the ones submitting a
lot of the early content and for the
first week for the first two weeks we ax
submitted under different usernames of
course you did so that like someone
showing up for the first time would
understand it wasn't just Stephen alexis
submitting links on this weird-looking
website it was like anyone can and and
the moment we knew it was working was a
month there about a month in when we
just used the website like anyone else
we just went on and just read stuff and
vote didn't submit anything and it just
worked like there were enough people
there weren't a lot there were enough
though that we're contributing and it
was good content and and that was when
all right we knew we weren't totally
wasting our lives and so you you get
this initial funding from Y Combinator
that's to develop right Bennett then if
they like the idea do they like how do
you how are you making money the first
year so so we raise twelve so we got
twelve thousand dollars from Y
Combinator six grand per founder and and
then at the end of the three months they
have this demo day now today demo day is
like it's one of the most sought after
demo days for anyone doing early-stage
tech investing Ashton Kutcher all the
celebrity pho like it is a scene back
then it was like Paul's twelve rich
friends in a room in Boston who were
just like why are we here and and we
Steve and I ended up raising seventy
thousand dollars now to us that was a
lot of money cuz we were like we're not
paying ourselves anything like we could
live off this for a year and a half two
years this is amazing
today you know a typical company is
gonna raise a million million and a half
at that same stage but back then we just
had different different mentality and
and and we thought are great we raised
70 so that we have 82 we were very lean
I mean that's the other great thing too
when you come right out of college your
standard of living is really low and
it's a great time to start a company
because you hopefully don't have any
dependents you're fine living cheap like
it's a good time to start a company so
then what was breakthrough
you know once once you started using the
site with like a number of people yeah
did it slow growth or all of a sudden
you know Bill Gates has started using
our website I well that that was a that
was a big moment but it never felt
like reddit it's consistently doubled
basically every year since the start but
it's over ten years and you look at
stories like I'm a snapchats what
everyone's talking about right now but
even Instagram still and that growth is
obscene like in and reddit never grew
that fast it kept growing consistently
so it never felt like this kind of
whiplash like oh wow whoa but there were
these there were definitely moments when
we kind of thought all right like this
is this is a new milestone like when the
president did an AMA I guess was four
three four years ago like that was
amazing and he also did it from
Charlottesville coincidentally and so is
a room right it was already pretty huge
I mean yeah it was there an earlier it
was it really just a slow go there was
never a whoa we just went up by a
thousand decks because know of somebody
you know you think about Oh so-and-so
tweeted something and then a company
blows up or so-and-so's on snapchat or
you know it's interesting that snapchat
or Instagram they all blow up everybody
jumps on the bandwagon of then of the
quote will it be the next thing right
because of Reddit and the other
predecessors that didn't have that mm so
you know well and because of the way
social media works now which was not the
case when you guys were yeah I mean
that's we do we watched you know we
watched Twitter get started
we watched Instagram we've seen all
these come up and it has occupied this
other here's what it is I think the
growth has been very consistent and it
had we've had milestones for sure there
was a there was a rally to restore
sanity and/or fear that's Stephen
Colbert dad that was it wasn't it it
looks like it was started by some random
user on reddit who had this idea of
doing this rally but it the rally
sorry was already in the works
beforehand but what happened over the
span of a couple months was I know
Stevens the son of north south carolina
so let's just go easy on him but he
really did a great job sort of egging on
redditors and to get his attention they
ended up raising he's on the board of
donors shoes
I think they raised eight hundred
thousand
dollars for basically the explicit
purpose of getting Stevens attention to
hold this rally and so watching that
happen was another one of those moments
where it's like what is going on and and
I I don't think it I don't think it's
been as explosive or it's been as like
oh we got to be there because every one
of the other social media platforms
plays really well with celebrities I can
tell whether you're a brand like the New
York Times whether you're a brand like
Lady gaga I can tell you or your people
like here is how you play on facebook
Instagram snap chats a little trickier
but like there are rules of the road for
how to do that and it benefits you as a
celebrity mm-hmm because reddit is just
a username and because like what could
be on the front page of Reddit could
just be a dude who took a photo of his
cat and it was really interesting and
millions of people are gonna see it it
doesn't it is it is more democratic in
the sense that it is less about who you
are and more about what you have to say
is that right but is that why it's all
about text I think the first time you go
to read is that what's will all the text
yeah I mean I have to read yeah is that
reddit is the YouTube for text I it's
yeah that's mostly a hangover frankly
it's mostly designed hangover from 2005
just because like image hosting back
then sucked like the reason imager
exists which was born out of Reddit was
because image hosting was terrible if
you linked to an image and you got a
deluge of reddit traffic that image host
would probably go down and would have
all these obnoxious ads to top it all
off and so like a lot of this stuff
evolved and I mean a lot of reddit has
stayed constant when it comes to the
like I said the aesthetics of it and the
text heaviness of it is that not a
strength of of the site oh it is it is
it really democratizes all of the
content it really it it's a level
playing field if you're Lady Gaga or if
you're if you're Pamela the Armenian
woman yes what have you a much worse
than the Army was made of it doesn't
you know you're just gonna get your nice
text out there you might get a little
thumbnail but yes and and I think what's
interesting is I think that's part of
the reason why so we have you know their
their communities on reddit like are
writing prompts which are amazing I mean
you anyone can go up there and just put
up a writing prompt and you'll get
amazing submissions from really talented
writers who are writing entire
narratives in the comments and and stuff
like that is unique to read it just
because of the the platform works so
well for text there are parts there's a
whole like what's a good example like
food porn earth porn there are all these
safe for work porn communities that are
just it's like beautiful high-res
photography of like Earth or you know
space or food and and it's funny how
reddit works for that um even though the
photos are still not the like primary
focus in part because the discussions
around them all the text is really
really interesting and and I like I said
I don't that was not something we
thought about and we're like yes this is
what read it will be it just sort of
happened that way and it's kind of
created its own culture I mean you
talked earlier about the aesthetic and
feeling a pressure to change but I can
only imagine I want to know what changes
you've made over the years but I also
want to know the response to those
changes because I can only imagine the
backlash that you would get if you if
and when it's tidied up to you know when
something like Twitter or whatever
launches today it's like the aesthetic
is such a big part of it yes just
because of the timing you know when it
came about but now you guys are kind of
up against that
yeah it's we would never so the guiding
principle I mean you could tell this was
our first everything I pretty sure this
was the first web app Steve or I had
ever built we just graduated from
college we're clearly I'm really proud
of my mascot designing skills but I mean
I take responsibility for choosing
Verdana as the font I've read it like I
there's a lot of like design Baggett's
just because I'm not but the red-eyes
reddit thing you design that yeah I was
I was bored in and you're out I drew
very well very that one I will totally
take credit let's take a little tangent
give us give us
just give us the rationale behind that
oh dude I was bored in class and I was
doodling and I drew this thing that I
thought would make for a good mascot for
a site that we still hadn't figured out
what it was gonna do all I knew is at
this point we've been accepted into Y
Combinator and I had a couple months
left in school and we knew we were gonna
build the front page of the internet but
we had no idea what the anything was
gonna I was gonna work or what I was
gonna do but I was hell-bent on having a
mascot because I felt like but then what
is it it's an alien from the future it's
a time-traveling alien it I like I maybe
it's a little bit nibbler subconsciously
from Futurama maybe it's a little bit
snork I've heard that from folks that
short-lived kids show like it really was
a bored doodle but then I went home
through it into photo no paint shop pro
oh yeah yeah and it was a cracked copy
but I threw it in there and and tidied
it up a little bit it was like this is
gonna be our icon this chimera mascot
and the only rationale I can give you is
the time-traveling part was important
because if it time traveled from the
future that means we did not fail right
as a company your doodle came from the
future yes that's a great job I mean not
really but the the story of it what's
crazy
you can bet Steve that that's all that
mattered yeah man dude it's from the
future yeah and then read it the name
that's just a play on words yeah we were
trying to get snoo Snew like still
people would ask what's new and we'd be
like exactly but the guy who wanted it
yeah the guy who wanted it to sell it
wanted four grand and we were like nope
so I'm just looking for other domain
names and I found reddit was available
it was almost spelled Ari I'm I bought
it re di TT as well as re d di t and for
like a day I was calling it the the
former but then one of my friends talked
me out of it and so we don't read did it
yeah I know is yeah what was I thinking
but how did AMA start randomly some user
so the the ask reddit community which
has always been a pretty popular once
you go on the ask a question you know
people answer had someone who came on
there and instead of asking question
they said oh I'm so and so ask me
anything and everyone in that community
was like what are you doing like that's
not how this works go start your own and
so they did and they called it hi Emma
and the I am a community is you know
that's the home to just I mean daily
multiple just amazing real-time
crowd-sourced interviews and now other
communities on reddit have sort of
picked up the AMA thing meme just like
app replies on Twitter this is all very
organic stuff great and and it's great
if you go on our science the science
community on one of the science
communities on reddit
they'll have regular AMAs with like
legit scientists practicing in the field
I was at a science conference in San
Jose last week and everyone was telling
me I'm obviously not a scientist but
actual scientists were telling me that
those reddit AMA s those science animes
are one of the best ways to bring
science to the public and you'll know
they are posers by their lies well
here's what's here's what's cool so they
do a certain amount of vetting where you
have to like you know you can you can
verify whether it's through Twitter or
whatever that like I am Who I am dr.
so-and-so but what happens on the
science AMAs in particular is if you
aren't like if you're slipping up in the
answers that you're giving like there
are other scientists reading that stuff
yeah who we're gonna call you out in
real time and it's happened on a couple
of occasions and it gets a little
awkward but you know you're
self-regulating yeah and this is how the
Internet I mean like someone's
correcting the President on his AMA I'm
sure there's probably one or two some of
them are pretty rare slip-ups but like
you know when I first heard about AMAs
oh people are gonna answer anything but
like the president is not gonna answer
anything you can add anything but he
ain't gonna answer it
but there are people who some well you
might get some like whoa answers you
have you have any examples of that yeah
this one so Anna this is also a slight
shameless plug for the reddit podcast so
I interviewed him and hasn't dropped yet
but we had a amazing interview we
mmm the guy goes by double dude on the
internet he is he has two fully
functioning penises they're fully
functioning fully functioning yeah and
he goes into vivid detail about what he
can do with them
and this is a horizontal or vertical
orientation uh wait wait that's the only
question oh wow I mean so you'll have to
read the AMA he did an AMA that spanned
I think 36 hours like he just answered
he's got double the stamina he mean you
got him Yeah right you should you should
read the it's fascinating because it
really it has because it's a real-time
kind of crowdsource to interview format
and the best stuff gets voted up like
you really get this atmosphere of it
being like just a bunch of people around
a table just asking someone questions
and it we have celebrities all the time
tell us like this was the best interview
I have done ever
but what because it just feels like a
double penal yes drop did he drop like a
bombshell
he he talked he answered imagine every
question going through your head right
now including you listeners about what
it's like to live a life with two fully
functioning penises and nothing was
off-limits so it gets a little
not-safe-for-work but when I followed up
with him and when we spoke about it for
the podcast it was like a whole nother
side to him because he started talking
like the stuff that we were interested
in and the advantage that upvoted gives
us is that we can have someone who does
this amazing AMA who's talking for 36
hours to millions of people answering
all their questions about everything you
can imagine and then we can come back
and be like alright we saw what happened
there that was amazing but like let's
talk more like let's try to understand
you as a person not just the spectacle
of being this dude with two penises so
it's not just a freak show he's a human
being yes but I do have to ask ya you
were in the room with him no I was very
very secretive yeah he did we did this
over Skype I don't even know his name I
need so you didn't see him no you didn't
see that I did not I I mean it has been
verified let's just say
not personally he is who he says he is
so you sold mmm
reddit yes when did that happen and why
2006 for a variety of reasons really
really it was yeah it was insane I mean
that was that was part of it right it
was 18 months 16 octoroon
anyway 16 18 months into it and to be 22
23 and have the opportunity for like
that kind of life-changing thing to
happen I really for me personally I did
not want to that up because it seemed
absurd right we working on this thing
for 60 once like it was going well but
it seemed absurd and I had a bunch of
other I had a lot of personal stuff
going on at the time too with my mom and
it just it was it was the kind of thing
where I did not want to because who
knows what was gonna happen
I did not want 10 years from now to be
looking back on that moment being like
you idiot you greedy idiot and and so it
was it was pretty much a no-brainer for
me well the best seriously the best
phone call I've ever made in my life
well two phone calls where the first
phone call it made to my mom when the
you know the money cleared and
everything was done and I told her like
thank you for believing in me for the
last 22 years and then the second best
call was it should have been to my dad
but I was calling the Washington
Redskins ticket office upgrading his
season tickets from the nosebleeds front
row and then I called him those were the
best like those were the best two phone
calls my life and I'll never have a
better phone call than that and and so
for me it was totally worth it and now
you know I stayed with the company for
another three years a little over three
years then did the Armenia thing for a
minute came back was an advisor to the
company for the last few years been on
the board and about three months ago
rejoined the company in a full-time role
as executive chair and and now I'm back
and this company is is so much bigger
and and I just I'm thrilled I'm thrilled
to be back him so so being back you know
ten years later is there a sense of you
know is there ever since of regret or is
it like no I'm glad
everything worked out this way and I'm
back and it didn't happen the way it did
I I would be such an if I regretted
anything that has happened to me in the
last like seven or eight night well I
guess nine years since we sold reddit it
is like everything I've been able to do
and I mean I literally I have this is
the big thing I'm always I mean like I
know how lucky I've been this is part of
the reason why things like Kiva are so
interesting to me because I know that
like I could have a genetic cousin who
especially at least in Armenia who like
would have just had the bad luck of
being unfortunately just born in Armenia
like I was born in New York like right I
just got a bunch of advantages and I've
lived every day since college looking
forward to my work and like that alone I
mean I know the job as my parents did
like I worked enough jobs at like Pizza
Hut to know the difference and I so
appreciate being able to look forward
what I do every day and and so the fact
that I've been able to do that for every
day since college because of reddit
because of that sale like I have no
regrets whatsoever have you and Steve
just continue to work together how what
does that relationship been like so we
so we both left right at about the same
time he went got married and then he
started enough said I know what happens
at marry well he started he had another
company in him and his travel search
site called Hipmunk like chipmunk about
the sea and and I rejoined up with him
about a week or two before they launched
to sort of run I created their mascot as
well it sort of run all the public
facing sort of marketing PR whatever
social media stuff and yeah it's been
that's that's a whole nother amongst as
big as read it is now and and if you
need any flight or hotel bookings you
should use it you know you talk about
growing up and working the pizza job and
things like that and kind of have a
perspective but a little bit um a little
bit of personal yeah I get it what I
mean are you the type of person did you
always have that natural entrepreneurial
confidence that led to I'm gonna create
a business some night I'm gonna
like that epiphany at Waffle House was
that out of the blue are you the kid
that ran the lemonade stand or was it
reddit that then gave you confidence to
start all the other things that I know
you've started before coming back to
Reddit I I was doing I was ok all my
friends we they're my best friends these
are guys I've known since kindergarten I
was an only child so they're basically
like my brothers I was definitely the
one who was the entrepreneurial one in
the sense that like when we were gonna
have a land party and that's all we knew
I literally never went to a party that
wasn't a land party at college I would
be the one sort of like organizing
getting done and I never ran the
lemonade stand but I was but the land
party was your idea - yes yeah and like
and like let's do this and I'm gonna
make it happen
yes that's the personality from a lot
yes and and I was you know and I'd be
the one who'd manage our quake 2 clan
for competitive gaming although it's so
much mad competitive gaming so much
better now that always make them are
they but you've always been crazy enough
to believe yes you should actually do
the ideas you have yeah and and I'm and
I had a dad who so this was awkward when
we launched Hipmunk my dad's a travel
agent still still a travel agent in 2015
and he started an agency on his own in
Western Maryland probably sorry dead 15
years ago it was a minute ago and so I
saw that Oh even longer maybe 20 but I
saw that he was starting that while was
in high school and so I liked it it
demystified starting a company it was a
very different company right I mean on
the phones all day booking flights and
stuff but like I could see that model
and I could see at work and any managed
to survive the dot-com like explosion of
online travel which is to his credit
like he found a niche the secret is old
people that is how you keep a travel
agency in business in 2015 people who
don't want to use the internet to book a
book a trip but uh so you kind of lay -
oh yeah for sure and and I'll tell you
the other thing - so my so my mom
immigrated from Germany when she was
like 24 20
five so while she was basically the
other thing I had in perspective was
like at the same time I was starting a
company she was basically changing her
entire life now Germany is obviously a
country that's you know very much a
first world country but it's a very
different culture a very different
language and all of her relationships
and connections pretty much ended when
she left and she basically said it I'm
going to New York I want to be with this
dude my dad and and this is what I want
my new life to be and like she never I
mean she got a GED like her whole life
in Germany was basically irrelevant in
America and and so seeing that - really
made me think well like if this is the
hardest thing I'm gonna do like this
isn't so bad
and and it really I don't know it helped
it helped me see it helped me demystify
entrepreneurship and at the same time
just kind of like put in place just how
not courageous it was I mean yes it's
risky but like at the end of the day
there are especially when you're a 22
year old with no obligations like coming
out of school there are much much more
dangerous and like risky things that I
could be doing right well and since that
initial you know you kind of started in
a place where there was an early failure
mm with mm-hmm
one day since it's gonna be a thing
since then what hasn't worked mmm I mean
there been a lot of little projects like
okay here's a good example so we are
reddit finally bought alien blue on iOS
so if you read reddit on your Apple
device you should download alien blue
but before that who we had I launched an
app called I read it because I wanted
people the hope was that people would
say like originally was just they would
say like I read it on reddit and I think
that happens I don't know but then when
the iPhone comes out and everyone's like
apps apps apps I'm like great redemption
we can finally do some cool on a smart
phone let's build an app and we ended up
this was a good lesson in not
outsourcing developer work but we ended
up spinning up this I reddit app which I
thought was such a clever name it wasn't
and and it was just not it was not a not
a good look there are plenty of projects
plenty of products like that we had to
essentially shutter it I think it's
still on the App Store but like there
are so many missteps and the great thing
is isn't usually no one's paying
attention to it because that's why it
was a misstep was that no one used it or
no one liked it then alien blue was
doing the same yeah it's just a much
better execution of a way to browse
reddit in an app like that was it and
something he's a random he was a
developer in Australia a single
developer just making this app out of
passion and did an amazing job with it
mm-hmm sounds like your experiences both
the failures and the success
[Music]
you rolled those up in into a book and
into empowering other people to
demystify entrepreneurship for them
right yeah no and without their
permission you talk about gatekeepers
and how well you can do something
without their permission
right yeah and the fact that like and it
I I don't want entrepreneurship just
sounds like a fancy special word like
III I think we do a really great job
especially in this country celebrating
entrepreneurship which is awesome I
think that's great but it's tends to put
the people who do it on these pedestals
where people are like okay this person
was able to do it because they are
different in these ways and the other
and I like that's not for me
and I want especially in this age where
like so many industries are being
reinvented by people who have no read
like like who like what what radio
station is you guys campaign in order to
get a show created right like what like
there are there are so many ways to be
entrepreneurial now and it's it's not
just people who want to build the next
reddit or the next SoundCloud it's
people who want to use those platforms
to be great and and hack it right I mean
I can certainly relate we talked about
gatekeepers a lot within the
entertainment industry having done the
television show thing a couple of times
and then you know finding our voice in
our audience directly through YouTube
the gatekeeper was removed you know for
everyone to create whatever they wanted
to create on YouTube when we were
grown-up you were either successful as
an artist
or you were starving artist right it was
like binary he was one of the other yeah
and now it's like as better and better
platforms come as sort of smarter and
smarter ways to monetize those
relationships happen in a way that fans
love and artists love like they're gonna
be people coming up who just have a
different view on creativity who will
think like there's actually another way
like it's not just I have to be jay-z or
I'm a starving artist but like I can
actually make a living making stuff that
I really care about that is really
interesting for an audience of people
who really love what I do and by cutting
out the middleman and because the cost
of distributing it is basically zero
thanks to the internet like I can
actually find a way to make a living
doing this stuff and a lot of these
business models are being created right
now but I am such a believer that's such
a believer in it India I guess this is
one of the reasons you're a huge
advocate of net neutrality mmm and
you've been fighting that fight for
years are you how do you feel about that
right now what do you think about the
latest FCC like a year ago I was putting
up ads in DC bus stops about net
neutrality and having and contacting the
FCC and I remember the atmosphere back
then was forget it
Wheeler's like former lobbyists for the
telcos like your host cable companies
spend more money than anyone else almost
anyone else I think right see the
writing on the wall just to bring
everyone up to speed was didn't gonna
have yeah Comcast and Verizon are gonna
have their way and forget it you're not
just gonna be able to put any you know I
can it's not gonna be a level playing
field it's you anyone wants to put
something on the internet it's going to
be it's gonna be downloaded by people
with power and money yeah so to speak
yeah and the people who have the power
and money will be able to prioritize
their stuff which it would feel like
television it would feel like the gates
here the gates are being did yeah yeah
and it and it flows it's it's not even
it's it's not even limited to just
content creators because they're all
they would all all be affected but it's
even the next platform so like the the
thing that caught a lot of people's
attention was Verizon was a calm guy
right it's either Comcast Verizon basic
he called up Netflix and was like hey
Netflix it looks like your service to
our customers is really really right now
don't know don't know why that is I bet
if you paid us more money we could fix
that for you
like straight-up like mafia style
extortion and and as soon as as soon as
Netflix paid up the service rates went
back up and everything was great now
they did pay they did pay and and this
set a really dangerous precedent because
in this world where a Netflix or anyone
with money or power can can buy that
kind of higher quality and access and
because the cable companies have that
leverage to be able to pull that switch
and decide like when the cable companies
decide who the winners and losers are
we're hosed because it doesn't just
affect the content creators it also
affects like the next Netflix like I did
a lot of investing these days I want to
invest in the next Netflix I'm an mi
gotta have a netflix shareholder but I
still want to invest in that girl who's
in her dorm room right now and he's
gonna build a next Netflix killer
because that's how innovation works in a
world where Netflix has that kind of
power where we don't have net neutrality
or sorry where Verizon and Comcast have
that kind of power and we don't have no
neutrality you actually get innovation
like the next Netflix that gets killed
before we even get started because they
don't have a level shot because they
don't have the deal that Comcast makes
with the incumbent and they lose not
because they're worse but just because
the cable company chose who the winner
was where are we right now
if you're yes monitoring the front lines
so we're doing we're doing very well if
you're the mayor of the internet Forbes
that said yeah I we're we are doing very
very well I'm not celebrating right now
because we still you know any decision
by the FCC still can be meddled with by
Congress and fortunately Congress has
been I think one of the least productive
ever at least I mean that's not we're
not that's not a fortunate thing but
regarding this issue it is because at
least it doesn't seem like legislation
will pass anytime soon that could undo
net neutrality coming from the FCC but
but we'll have to wait and see and
what's nice and I think this is the
thing we saw during SOPA and PIPA we saw
again here during that neutrality was so
many
websites came together so many websites
came together and so many content
creators came together and they all went
to their respective audiences and
communities and said this is important
make a call
I mean signing petitions great sending
email is great but like make a call it's
old-school but it really makes a
difference and they delivered I mean
whether it was signing petitions the FCC
where we had I think was a record number
of petitions fighting for title 2 which
is the the sort of wonky way of saying
that neutrality in broadband and a
record number of phone calls to the
offices of Senators and Representatives
just to say like this is an issue I care
about and it only it really only takes a
minute or two and it actually makes a
hell of a difference yeah we we went
dark
on good mythical morning one day as part
of that so we you know that was thank
you a little part of that no but that
that stuff matters because what there
are a lot of people who are used to the
top-down world who are really
intimidated and scared by this because
when there were three major news
networks like you knew who was dictating
what was the news of the day in a world
where there are so many disparate
influencers and so many disparate places
to get that news it means there's all
these different communities and each one
of them has a way of just like any
community a way of being talked to a way
of being motivated and that's great
because it means that like you all know
how to talk to your people in the right
way how to get them excited how to get
them energized and like I don't know how
to do that like and then they have their
voice to talk back yes or to become a
voice in their own right and every you
know so it's power to the people it is
it is certainly a very beautiful thing
that again is embodied in Reddit it kind
of as I've thought about it and right
and I have talked about it a question
we've had is what does your experience
with Reddit reveal about humanity
um I mean people good or people bad it
is I think all of social media at the
end of the day is a reflection I mean
all this stuff is a reflection of people
right the good stuff the bad stuff I
think the hope is and the thing that we
see
I mean multiple times a day are people
who don't know each other who don't even
usually have their real name associated
with an account they're just that you
know I don't know and lay sure 24 write
some alias yeah being amazingly
thoughtful and just good for no reason
other than just because and I certainly
feel like in a world where traditionally
it has been whether whether you have
power because you're a major corporation
and you want to sell me more deodorant
or whether you're a politician who wants
to be re-elected you want to make us
fear you want to make us worried that
and that dude won't go on a date we may
because I smell bad and so I got to get
this deodorant or I'm gonna be in
trouble so I need this person to protect
me and so I should vote for them and
it's it happens now so often that we see
these things we're just disparate people
all over the world who don't actually
know each other are coming together just
to be decent just to be kind whether
it's you know seeing hundreds of
thousands of people participate in a
Secret Santa gift exchange every year
with total strangers just sending gifts
the best gifts of the year often for
these people are gifts they're sending
to total strangers
oh yeah sometimes it is but I mean but
reddit also has to decide okay we're not
gonna allow child porn on our website
right so yes I how do you at a certain
point but how do you draw that line oh
well that one's that one's very easy
that one's easy but then like what does
it say about humanity as my point is
that you had yes that's an easy line to
draw but you had to draw it you know
there's you know you've got the best of
people and the worst of people coming
out whenever you give people free rein
should everyone really be given free
rein um well I don't know the
alternative right I mean we can the eye
notwithstanding like actually getting
into people's heads and reading their
thoughts like the ultimate the ultimate
solution is just going to be trying to
encourage the better behavior and
there's you know like I said there's
been when they
do something good like I mean the Boston
bombing thing that happened people
trying to do the right thing and then it
wasn't you know right so it's people
being bad it's good people accidentally
being bad yeah
and that was it that was a difficult
situation too because the thread that
missed' Dennis so there was a particular
comment thread that misidentified this
innocent young man as being a potential
suspect in the Boston bombing that was
one of millions on the site that no one
was looking at and unfortunately a
couple of journalists like tweeted out
reddit hat like journalists tweeted like
reddit may be on to something
I think they discovered who the Boston
bomber was and and that's not to absolve
you know that redditor of posting that
comment but it's we're in this dangerous
ecosystem where so much there's so much
pressure now on being fast and because
you know the Internet's producing
content 24/7 that it's gonna be more
important than ever that we are right
and I don't know how that looks like the
the rate at which we're gonna have
information coming out is only gonna
increase everyone with a smartphone is
now a reporter they're not a journalist
but they are a reporter and and in a
world where there's going to be more and
more information spreading it's going to
be more and more important I think for
like journalists to do that great job of
sifting the signal from the noise yeah
and I I think that you know you had you
you have to solve these things or at
least take a stance and you know with
the infrastructure with it or the gentle
hand I mean if you think about it with
everything about like the Wikipedia
principle I know so many people who
anytime you say that you got some
information from Wikipedia they're like
well that's not reliable but it's the
whole thing that like what you're giving
and taking if you have a few people in
charge of information just because they
have some sort of credentials you still
there they go unchecked versus having a
democratized process of people
presenting information that's
self-correcting you know I think that
our generation is is definitely more
prone to trust the what self-regulated
the collective the hive yeah
and I and it's it is this is gonna be a
constant struggle and it makes sense
given how much we have been misled by
authorities I mean if you look right
whether it's whether it's wars overseas
whether it's don't worry everyone needs
to have a mortgage don't worry everyone
needs to have student loan debt don't
worry we've got the economy covered
everything's safe like I think in the
last twenty years you have a generation
that's really looked around skeptically
at a lot of the I mean Brian Williams
can't even keep a story straight about
right now it's something that like it it
doesn't mean that crowdsourcing is the
panacea but I think what is interesting
is that so many people are looking to
like they're looking to these
technologies entities this sort of
aggregated wisdom or amount of wisdom
but this aggregated insight into what is
interesting and what is relevant and
then hoping that things get vetted
essentially in real time and it's being
in it being worth the risk I mean
there's gonna be risk involved in
however we receive information and
spread information but seems like it's
gonna be that the risk is lower when
there's more people involved well and I
you know I'm not just interested in the
solutions in the future but going back
to the whole question about humanity hmm
I think that it separate from everything
we just said it reddit provides a window
into call it what you will call it the
human soul or consciousness that's 200
million people yeah so personally again
well you know I think where you were
going to a place of it became as read it
became a source of hope in humanity for
you hmm
but I think people who kind of graze
reddit yeah oh that's that's a scary
place you know I don't know I'm an
outsider hmm or there's some you know
the Internet is scary when people just
can kind of express themselves so I mean
where do you where do you land what's
your what's your what's your view of
that the consciousness the view of
humanity
well I mean this is I I don't know I
think I mean I'm a pretty active
consumer of most social media and there
are days when I just need to shut off
Twitter there are days when I need to
shut off even Instagram and I'm just
like stop there are days when I need to
close reddit right there are days when I
need to unplug from it all because it
really is a reflection of anyone who's
got an internet connection and I think
it is it is because it is that glimpse
into people and like I said this is
about 200 million people right this is
like if this were a country I mean this
is 2/3 decides the United States
I couldn't even generalize good like I
couldn't even generalize the state of
North Carolina let alone generalizing
you know 200 million people but I think
what people are now searching for more
than ever is authenticity I think we've
had whether it's because of by you know
whether it's because of over-aggressive
PR firms whether it's because if you
know people who come off as these
infallible tastemakers and deciders
we're telling us what's right and it's
weird paternalistic way I think they
want authenticity and they'll understand
like we understand that bad things
happen in this world right there there
are not nice they're not good people but
the vast majority of us are actually
reasonable decent people I mean I've
seen this literally all over the world
like at the end of the day when you're
breaking bread with someone no matter
where they are no matter what their
faith no matter what their whatever like
they just want to see that their family
is well and that hopefully their kids do
a little better than they do and I think
if we didn't have I mean as long as we
have humans we're gonna have that range
but I really do see across social media
more reasons to be hopeful than not hmm
and you know you bring authenticity is
the value of whether you're good or bad
the overarching value of of realness of
being real is is a valuable commodity if
you if if there's bad in you
I think everyone and yeah if there's if
there's bad and good in everyone then
I'd much rather see it for what it is
then cover it up for what it's not I
think that is it's an interesting value
to kind of add to the mix when you're
talking about you know good and evil or
good and bad or pure motives or tainted
motives you know it's just slathering on
that authenticity or maybe pulling back
yeah and back to coverage we're
sensitive we're so the onus especially
when somebody calls something tries to
make something bad seem good we're
really sensitive to that you know that's
a we we have a keen this generation has
a keen sense of that kind of thing it's
what you're getting at yeah and I see it
I mean even in the way celebrities I
mean like why was it such a big deal in
the mainstream media that lourd posted a
photo of herself with like pimple cream
on because I think for one world that's
really wheat like what what's going why
would a famous person be showing
something like that but for all of her
fans that was the relationship they have
yeah and and I mean that's one sort of
silly glimpse into it but I think social
media represents people you know warts
and all and and for like I said I I have
many more reasons to believe in people
than I do don't because of it the the
hope for me is that we can keep pushing
we can keep showing people more of the
stuff that's happening every day
that is just decent and reasonable and
good and they will actually see more of
that it's hard right on the nightly news
right that's just that means murder
reports it's hard through so many media
channels to see that kind of glimpse and
I think it means more right if you had a
place where only like where and this is
not to justify imperfect behavior but
like I said we're I don't think any of
us is a hundred percent pure and good
and and I think few people would believe
that but for a while we've had a lot of
like the way stuff has been communicated
to us has been with this misperception
that like this person is an authority
this person is a hundred percent right
this person is perfect as you're seeing
the polished you're seeing the Brian
Williams version on the night
being that person telling you here's
what's important because we're now
saying all right well let's all figure
out what's important what's the news of
the day together we know that comes with
just all of the the scope of it and the
fact that more often than not good stuff
happens is even more interesting and I
think meaningful because we know that
that's not like that that that is
happening in spite of the fact that
humans are not perfect always good
people okay but let's ask the most
important question of the day okay
which is for a content creator like a
youtuber how do you use reddit to get
more views oh this is where this is
where we have just keep it simple let's
really have that breakdown this is so
it's it's hard because it's not as
obvious as like just it's not as obvious
as I get a bunch of followers or whatnot
it really is make great stuff which I
hope everyone aspires to do and then
when it bubbles up on reddit get engaged
so you know if if you're and you can run
periodic searches there's a you think
don't come up with a username that's not
you and post your own work astroturf yes
exactly
oh okay well yeah and and it is here's
the thing right so your video could be
submitted to any number like 8,000 Plus
communities and each one of those
communities is different and distinct
and so if it gets submitted to like the
videos community that's a pretty general
large community but maybe it's music or
maybe it's like there's a Balkan folk
music community that I recently
discovered but each one of them is gonna
have a different discussion about it
because they are like it's like imagine
like a digital community center and it's
just a matter of like imagining you're
walking into that and just saying like
hey what's up I made this thing like I'm
glad you liked the choice of instrument
or what I like it is in that way it is
actually a much much closer parallel to
real human life than I think a lot of
the other platforms because like I mean
like we go on Twitter and we're
just shouting and and hopefully there's
some followers who might catch what
we're saying but you would never walk
into a room just be like hey check out
my thing I'm out of here hey yeah and
I'm leaving it and it is come out and
like and like the the message board mom
we didn't invent the message board but
that model lends itself much more to
basically just engaging like a human so
that's the advice is just be human and
then find ways or make great stuff and
then and then join conversations when
they're happening okay so you're of no
help but no I'll let you sign the table
anyway yay yeah this has been really
cool thanks for hanging out with us well
there it was a near biscuit with Alexis
Ohanian tweet at him and let him know
what you thought of our conversation
Alexis Ohanian is his Twitter handle use
hash tag ear biscuits so we can be
included in that conversation guys
appreciate the feedback there also give
us a review on iTunes or leave a comment
well a good review I mean if you're
gonna say something bad don't say
anything no I mean any review is helpful
to you say what say what you feel guys
on iTunes or comment on soundcloud now
he introduced me not not to a concept
that I didn't know about but to a term
for a concept that I didn't know about
and that is astroturfing that's when you
basically pimp yourself your own post
out on reddit right which because it's
it's planning something fake yes yes
thanks for explaining that I'm not I'm
not kidding oh you didn't know I didn't
realize it until you just said that oh
[Music]
why I never heard the term either but i
but i but i got there and thought about
it for a second but I've asked her
turfed quite a lot I mean we don't know
now anytime recently but okay so we've
been doing this internet thing for a
long time we got started in oh six
so in Oh sick I would say in oh six and
oh seven maybe a little bit in oh eight
but really strong in oh seven probably
peaked in oh seven I did whatever
astroturfing is on YouTube I created a
number
fake names fake profiles to come in and
thumbs up and that thumbs up what did
you even do back then to comment I guess
you coming oh oh no I because it was
back in the day where there was so few
comments that one comment could really
make a difference you know could really
sway the conversation in like if people
were reacting badly to something right
it's kind of like what could top
comments do today but you're saying you
also did that on reddit more recently
yeah no not more recently I would say oh
eight would be the most recent that I
would have done that back out this video
that I didn't make cough and I and I
would never say that I didn't make it I
would just say you know it would be our
video and I mean I had like a reddit
profile that wasn't my name I mean I'm a
little ashamed of it especially now that
I've talked to Alexis are you but about
a desperate man to tell us what the no
IDs were no I can't I couldn't I could I
would be prepared but it would be
something like Doug McDermott or
something like that I mean I just a lot
of times I would put in my alias as I'll
put a mick in the front of the last name
I don't know why we couldn't do that
it's you you remember that it was you
yes you don't want to fall for it
yourself well you know wow that guy is
really nice he's really he's a super but
have you ever noticed that that's what
that's what criminals do with her
aliases so my name is Rhett mcLaughlin
then like my criminal name is like
Reggie make you know McClane you know
it's like in ml they don't want to
forget yeah you don't want to get too
off of what your real name is so a lot
of my alias has had the mick in them and
listen but you should be thanking me you
got to keep the initials the same so if
somebody calls you up by your initials
what are your initial rim oh yeah that's
me Reggie McLean but see here's the
thing you should be thanking me for this
because we may not be sitting here at
this round table of dim lighting right
now if if I had not cheated a little bit
I'm just kidding it what probably wasn't
effective and I'm a little ashamed of it
I apologize for astroturf ring it will
never happen again if you're doing it
right now you should immediately stop
thank you for listening to this ear
biscuit and forgiving Rhett along with
me for astroturf
talk at you next week okay
[Music]
[Music]